[Musique]
j'aimerais vous présenter deux
situations la première avec cette petite
fille
qui a eu peu de bonnes cartes entre les
mains un parcours difficile avec
beaucoup de souffrance de douleur
d'isolement
très tôt elle devrait apprendre à vivre
avec des douleurs physiques aigus des
attaques de panique quotidienne une
maladie dégénérative invalidante qui ne
se soigne pas une surdité ni
appareillable ni opérable un spectre de
l'autisme diagnostiqué très tardivement
et des paralysies qui l'amèneront à être
régulièrement en fauteuil manuel puis
électrique
bombarder dans 10 douleurs elle tombera
même dans le coma suite à un surdosage
et c'est pas la résine voudront une
noyade avec un arrêt respiratoire
comme 80% des femmes en situation de
handicap elle sera de violence
psychologique physique médicale
économique judiciaire
en fin de côté professionnel après lui
avoir promis 25 ans de chômage à la
sortie de ses études en plus des
discriminations elle subira
l'inadaptation de son poste par l'un de
ses employeurs ce qui lui vaudra
plusieurs mois de paralyser une
reconstruction partielle de la colonne
et une rééducation à vie
elle devra faire face aussi à la
précarité et l'abus des aidants
les violences lui auront également
laissé des traces
avec des troubles de la mémoire et des
troubles de politique
elle devra réapprendre à marcher se
tenir debout monter un escalier
[Applaudissements]
à côté de ça nous avons une femme à qui
la chambre la chance semble avoir souri
multi potentiel
audacieuse brillante elle réussit ses
études cumule les disques les diplômes
multiplie les domaines d'expertise
elle a fait plusieurs fois le tour du
monde à 25 ans elle faisait son premier
CES à Las Vegas elle a créé son propre
camionnette conseil en stratégie
internationale
elle a créé un incubateur à la créer sa
propre start-up une association et elle
est bénévole et engagée
pour l'entrepreneuriat féminin dans la
tech dans la diversité
elle a reçu différentes récompenses
elle est arrivée deuxième sur un pont du
Mondial juste après Microsoft
un reportage télévisé lui a été consacré
qui a fait plus de 2 millions de vues
sur les réseaux sociaux
elle est en train d'écrire un livre
elle sait ce qui est dans ses faire des
claquettes jouer du saxophone peindre
alors puisque aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de destin et de chance laquelle
selon vous a eu le plus de chance
alors vous l'aurez compris cette petite
fille c'est moi et je suis venue vous
dire aujourd'hui en étant devant vous
qu'on peut reprendre le pouvoir sur son
destin même après avoir été mis à terre
à plusieurs reprises
alors c'est un protestable la ville ne
va pas épargner je suis une femme
polyhandicapée ex victime de violence et
je ne peux pas faire une conférence sur
mes notes
mais au-delà de ça ce que je suis
et ce que j'ai vécu ne me définit pas je
suis ce que j'ai décidé d'être
personne ne peut ni le droit de le faire
à ma place
combien parmi vous on pensait
je n'ai pas eu de chance ou si j'avais
su alors il y a la chance il y a
l'imprévu
au hasard mais je suis venu vous parler
de la chance que l'on peut créer
soi-même
alors pour ça il y a plusieurs prérequis
donc j'aimerais vous preniez conscience
la première c'est que la vie est une
chance c'est une série incessante
d'opportunités alors ces essais
n'attendez pas que la chanson rendez
vous créez de vous-même
n'attendez pas non plus après les autres
sur l'écran d'accueil de mon téléphone
j'ai mis une phrase qui dit si tu
cherches quelqu'un pour changer ta vie
alors regarde-toi dans le miroir
tout le monde sans exception peut avoir
de la chance regardez-moi on aurait pu
imaginer que je ne puisse avoir que de
la malchance et pourtant sans super
pouvoir sans potion magique
avant tout vous devez y croire et en
être convaincu vous connaissez tous le
pouvoir de l'intention
alors croyez-y à commencer par vous-même
il n'appartient qu'à vous de reprendre
le pouvoir sur les événements ou au
moins la façon dont vous pouvez et
réagir parce que la chance c'est aussi
une question posture est-ce que je subis
un événement où est-ce que j'agis
est-ce que je suis une victime ou est-ce
que je suis une ex victime parce que
l'événement est passé
est-ce que je donne le pouvoir à une
personne un événement
de décider pour moi et de briser mes
rêves
j'ai un exemple frappant c'est mon petit
garçon après un événement dramatique qui
nous était arrivé je lui ai demandé ce
que tu veux qu'on change dans le projet
et il m'a répondu très sagement
maman ce n'est pas parce qu'il a eu un
caillou sur notre route et que des gens
se font mal comporter qu'on doit
abandonner
l'existence et les rencontres nos cultes
mais nous avons le pouvoir de décider ce
que nous en faisons
alors avoir de la chance c'est aussi une
question de stratégie et je vous cache
pas que c'est un peu pour ça que j'ai
choisi ce métier c'est qu'il permet de
créer la chance en trouvant des
solutions pour que les entrepreneurs
réalisent leur rêve
[Applaudissements]
Abraham Lincoln disait le meilleur la
meilleure façon de prédire l'avenir
c'est de le créer
alors soyez professionnels dans votre
approche de la chance définissez des
objectifs
évaluer la faisabilité de vos projets
définissez des plans d'action pour que
la chance soit au rendez-vous
en stratégie on considère que de toute
crise peut sortir une opportunité
parce que certes une crise bouscule mais
elle ouvre le champ des possibles
l'adversité est une chance elle vous
permet et même vous oblige à vous
dépasser à innover à trouver des
solutions
la maladie vous permet d'être plus
combatif plus volontaire
prenez conscience que c'est dans votre
zone d'inconfort que se trouve votre
croissance ce que vous connaissez ce que
vous maîtrisez ne vous apprend rien de
nouveau posez-vous la question quand
vous traversez une crise qu'est-ce que
ça m'apprend sur moi qu'est-ce que ça
m'apprend sur ma vie
être atteinte de surdité ni opérable ni
apparaîtrable m'a permis d'apprendre à
lire sur les lèvres si demain nous
sommes en visio que vous avez des
travaux à côté de vous n'entendez rien
qui sera la plus handicapée des deux
des obstacles vous en aurez toujours
à l'occasion d'un des projets que je
voulais lancer
on m'a objecter madame vous êtes une
femme handicapée alors restez chez vous
ne prenez pas de poste à responsabilité
ou encore prenez un associé valide
un obstacle se contourne mais ce que je
vais vous dire c'est que n'attendez pas
d'avoir toutes les bonnes cartes entre
les que ça n'arrivera jamais
faites différence une chance
il y a une phrase que j'utilise très
souvent parce que je la trouve
merveilleuse c'est la citation mais les
biches de père la différence est cette
chose merveilleuse que nous avons tous
en commun
mes différences mes épreuves sont une
formidable richesse
sans lesquels grâce auxquels je suis ce
que je suis devenu aujourd'hui et qui me
rendent unique
alors soyez vous-même ne serait-ce que
parce que si vous essayez d'être
quelqu'un d'autre vous allez être épuisé
nous sommes tous uniques nous sommes
tous différents
et nous avons tous du talent sans
exception
alors il y a des conditions de
réalisation forcément vous devrez faire
face à l'adversité plus persévérant le
dépassement de soi
mais soyez aussi conscient que vous
devez accepter de ne pas tout maîtriser
malheureusement nous sommes dans une
société
où on nous demande beaucoup de
performances où il y a des challenges
incessants
mais la chance
comporte une part d'imprévisibilité d'un
président
[Rires]
et nous traversons incessamment des
crises donc il faut apprendre à les
traverser
par ailleurs tenez vous prêt soyez
attentifs parce que le coup de chance
existe aussi
j'avais rendez-vous avec une amie dans
un café et à mon arrivée elle me dit
regarde est-ce que c'est pas la ministre
que tu souhaitais rencontrer
j'y suis allé au pire je ne pouvais que
la saluer elle m'a accordé 15 minutes
d'échange pour échanger sur mon projet
dépassez vos peurs
si je n'avais pas dépassé mes peurs je
n'aurais pas accepté de subir une
opération
qu'il me permettait qu'à 10% peut-être
de remarcher un jour
si je n'avais pas dépassé mes peurs je
n'aurais pas réussi à les porter plainte
soyez audacieux et prenez des risques
qu'avez-vous à perdre
si ce n'est de tenter votre chance
osez c'est déjà gagné et ça vous laisse
au moins une chance de réussir sinon
vous avez déjà perdu
relevez-vous et soyez patient
regardez-moi j'ai les 54 ans pour en
arriver là où je suis aujourd'hui donc
vous avez de la marge
par contre on a le droit de tomber
on a le droit d'être à terre
mais j'estime qu'on a le devoir et la
responsabilité de se relever
et sinon qu'est-ce que je laisserai
comme le son à mes enfants
alors la chance prenait là comme une
course d'obtacles à force de tomber vous
ouvrez de plus en plus vite de plus en
plus facilement
on ne l'est pas résilient on le devient
j'avais envie de vous partager quatre
clés alors très personnel mais qui m'ont
beaucoup aidé
ne soyez pas dans l'attente
est-ce que j'attends que la justice
rende son verdict pour me reconstruire
est-ce que j'attends que mon agresseur
me demande pardon pour avancer
est-ce que j'attends qu'on trouve un
traitement pour vivre
faites en short que chaque jour compte
cultiver l'optimisme
ce n'est pas être naïve c'est être
conscient de ses faiblesses de ses
limites mais de ne pas s'y attarder
c'est refuser la fatalité
en plus c'est un excellent rempart
contre la malchance
et plus vous verrez le bon côté des
choses moins vous serez impacté par les
obstacles
la grâce de l'émerveillement
alors pensez
au Petit Prince de Saint-Exupéry
célébrer ça petite victoire
se lever s'habiller honorer un
rendez-vous gérer sa douleur
ne passez pas à côté de tous les petits
miracles de la vie
à commencer par vous même
les gens sont souvent des miracles qui
s'ignorent
ensuite ouvrez la porte à l'espérance
Simone Veil disait seul l'espoir apaise
la douleur
l'espérance est un état de confiance
d'abandon
donner à chaque jour la chance d'être le
plus beau jour de votre vie et ne perdez
jamais espoir parce que vous ne savez
pas de quoi demain vous faites
alors vous savez quel serait pour vous
la pire des malchances
et bien ce serait celle que vous risquez
de laisser passer
je dois vous faire une confidence il y a
trois ans quasiment jour pour jour à
l'occasion du confinement je me suis
retrouvée dans un centre un foyer pour
les femmes victimes de violence
en état de choc paralysé sans infirmière
je venais de réussir à porter plainte
contre un escroc qui m'avait brisé volé
et qui se faisait même passer pour le
fondateur de ma start-up
je pensais avoir tout perdu et je me
voyais finir sourde paralysé à regarder
le plafond toute la journée
et pourtant j'avais ce rêve de faire un
jour un TEDx
pour les personnes qui passent par des
épreuves terribles
ou qui se sentent trop différents
si on avait dit à la petite fille dont
je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure qui
était muette
qu'un jour elle serait sur cette scène
et en plus pour vous parler de change
dans la région alors ne lâchez rien
si on considère que chaque jour est une
page blanche tous les matins vous avez
la chance de pouvoir écrire votre propre
histoire
il n'y a pas de fatalité on peut
reprendre le contrôle sur son destin
vous avez tous ce pouvoir extraordinaire
alors certes vous ne pouvez pas revenir
en arrière échanger le passé mais vous
pouvez dès ce soir construire votre
avenir et le décider
alors dès ce soir choisissez-vous faites
vous confiance construisez votre destin
pas à pas mais surtout ne laissez jamais
personne ni quoi que ce soit briser vos
rêves et n'oubliez pas
que vous êtes votre plus belle et plus
précieuse histoire alors prenez soin
[Applaudissements]